>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER,
THANK YOU.
TAMMY BRUCE IS PRESIDENT OF
INDEPENDENT WOMEN'S VOICE AND AN
HONORED GUEST ON THE SHOW.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE TAKEAWAY IS
WHAT WE ALREADY KNEW, A SYSTEM
THAT TELLS US IT'S BASED ON
MERIT IS NOTHING LIKE THAT AT
ALL.
IT'S A LIE.
>> IT IS A LITTLE BIT.
SOME KIDS GET INTO SCHOOL.
THEY WORKED HARD.
MAYBE THEY USED SCHOLARSHIPS.
WORKING JOBS GOING TO SCHOOL.
STUDIED FOR THE S.A.T. TEST AND
DID WELL ENOUGH GET TO IN.
WHAT WE ARE FINDING IS THERE IS
A PART OF THE SYSTEM WHERE SOME
YOUNG PEOPLE WERE PUSHED OUT TO
ALLOW THESE INDIVIDUALS TO GET
IN.
THAT'S THE BIGGEST PROBLEM HERE.
TAKING A SLOT FOR AN ATHLETE WHO
WORKED HARD ALL THEIR LIVES TO
GET THAT SCHOLARSHIP.
THAT'S ELIMINATED.
SOME PEOPLE SAY WHAT IS THE
HARM?
SOME YOUNG PEOPLE WERE SHUTOUT
OF THE PROCESS.
IN ADDITION TO THE FACT IT'S
CHEATING.
THE ACTIONS TAKEN BY INDIVIDUALS
WHO COULD HAVE EVERYTHING AS
THEY WANT.
IT'S A REMARKABLE THING FOR
AMERICANS WATCH UNFOLD.
THE GOOD NEWS WE ARE FOCUSSED ON
THESE ACTRESSES AND THEY ARE
BEHAVING DIFFERENTLY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IS
INVESTIGATING THE 8 COLLEGES
INVOLVED.
THIS ENTIRE SYSTEM HAS TO BE
LOOKED AT.
IT'S NOT JUST THE 8 COLLEGES
CAUGHT BEING INVOLVED.
IT'S AN INFRASTRUCTURE OF
ENTITLEMENT BECAUSE OF THE
LIBERALISM THAT GUIDES THAT
INSTITUTION AS A WHOLE.
>> Tucker: SINCE WE FUND THESE
INSTITUTIONS THROUGH TAX DOLLARS
AND TUITION, WHY SHOULDN'T WE
HAVE TRANSPARENCY IN THE
ADMISSION'S PROCESS AND KNOW HOW
PEOPLE GET INTO COLLEGE?
IT'S THE GATEWAY TO SUCCESS IN
OUR SOCIETY.
>> RIGHT.
WE HAVE 8 UNIVERSITIES, 6 ARE
PRIVATE.
TWO WERE PUBLIC.
EVEN IN PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS
LIKE HARVARD, CONSERVATIVES
COMPLAIN THAT WE GIVE RESEARCH
GRANTS TO THESE PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS.
THERE IS A LOT OF OTHER THINGS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER WAYS
THE FEDERAL MONEY FLOWS INTO
THESE INSTITUTIONS.
I THINK IT'S NAIVE TO SUGGEST
IT'S JUST A FEW OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, EARLIER
THIS MONTH WE LEARNED THAT
HARVARD IS INVESTIGATING THEIR
FENCING COACH WHO SOLD ALLEGEDLY
HIS HOME TO THE FATHER OF A
STUDENT TRYING TO GET IN FOR
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS MORE THAN
WHAT THE HOME WAS WORTH.
THERE IS A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS GOING ON AT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS HERE.
CLEARLY, WE SEE THAT THE
WASHINGTON STRUCTURE IS
DISSOLVING.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE FBI.
IT'S SCARY TO THINK THAT THE
HIGHER EDUCATION STRUCTURE IS
CORRUPT.
WE HAVE TO FACE IT.
IT'S LIKE IF YOU HAVE CANCER,